thanks like so as my question this is
this is a really the the evolution of a
conversation that's been happening
between several of us who are here in
the audience who will be speaking today
and tomorrow that we've been we've been
engaged with in small groups over the
last couple of years talking about
social science and computer science and
how they might work together and how
things might be be done differently and
this is really the first time that we've
kind of stepped out of the shadows into
a semi public forum so I'm looking
forward to getting some external impact
coming can I just before I get started
how many people here regard themselves
as social scientists okay so we've got
I've got some a good a good mixture of
people so so this is I'm going to try to
sort of set out the the guts of the
argument that we make in the white paper
that might just mentioned and hopefully
we'll we'll be able to sort of flesh
that out over the next couple of days
and I want to motivate this this
question that I'm asking in the in the
title with a really sort of a personal
observation that I've come to refer to
the bookshelf problem over the years so
I have a you know I still read physical
books I haven't migrated to a Kindle yet
and so I have a large bookshelf at home
and I have lots and lots of social
science books that I've that I've
acquired over the years and and when I
read any one of these books most of them
are I mean some of them are terrible but
but many of them are very good in there
they make plausible arguments and if you
just read them on there I'm you you
would sort of come away with a point of
view about the world and in particular
human behavior that would seem very
persuasive and interesting and possibly
even useful the the problem is that the
shelf as a whole doesn't make sense
right that if you if you pick up more
than one of these books you find other
points of view that are not just
different from the first one that you
read but are in fact logically
incompatible
or empirically incompatible they are
they are they are difficult to make
sense of together so just a you know
millions and millions of people have
read for economics and the basic
argument of for economics is you know
incentives matter that people do what
they do because of the particular
economic incentives that they face
millions and millions of people have
also read predictably irrational in fact
many of the same millions of people have
read both of these books and yet
predictably irrational says you know
people do what they do because of things
precisely other than economic incentives
right that they do things because of
they have all sorts of heuristics and
biases that drive their their behavior
and so if you read these two books
together you probably should feel
confused you probably should think these
are these are wildly incompatible views
of human behavior and it's possible that
to some extent you know each one of them
is true under you know more or less true
under different circumstances but
neither book tries to make that argument
each book just sort of takes the point
of view and says here's what explains
human behavior and the other book takes
a different point of view and says
here's what explains you human behavior
and it's just sort of left up to the
reader to try to figure out how these
things fit together and I would claim
that but that we have not in fact
figured out how these things fit
together and that there is no other book
on my bookshelf that takes on that task
and tries to make sense of the whole and
you can go through all these different
topics if we think about you know
performance of companies we have you
know many best-selling books like good
to great that that tell you how to how
to generate high performance in your
company and we have other books like the
halo effect that tell you all those
books are nonsense we have books that
tell us about how governments are
incapable of solving intractable social
problems and then and that markets are
great and then we have other books that
tell us that markets are incapable of
solving intractable social problems and
so you can just sort of go on and on and
on and any topic that you pick in the
social domain you have a similar kind of
problem which is that it's not just that
there's multiple points of view but that
they're largely talking past each other
right and so we have this sort of
proliferation of ideas but no sort of
one thing that you can or a coherent
message that you can take away from them
so this is what I refer to as the the
bookshelf problem and having spent you
know a couple of decades now reading
across various literature's in in in in
social science in in the scientific
literature I think that the same problem
applies to social science in in the sort
of more academic sense this is not just
a symptom of the trade publishing
industry not sort of taking problems
seriously and so in just one particular
example I got interested in
organizational performance a couple of
years ago and and decided to do some
reading and it turns out that I'm not
the only person who was confused so if
we go back to 1984 there's a nice couple
of papers in the 1980s that do a sort of
meta-analysis of the the field of
organizational performance and these
papers are really sort of a plea for
help right they're saying look there are
you know dozens if not hundreds of
theories of what drives organizational
performance like why some companies
perform better than others and and yet
there's no way for us to to make sense
of these theories like there's no sense
in which they are being put together we
don't have any generalizable principles
that come out of these theories we don't
even have a definition of performance
yet why do you think if there's a huge
literature on organizational performance
and you might at some point want to get
around to saying what you mean and it's
not that people don't say what they mean
it's that they say lots of different
things and they mean lots of different
things and those meanings are not easy
to reconcile with one another and as a
result there's not much of a connection
between the science of organizational
science and the practice so there's it's
sort of impossible you know I work in
Microsoft and a couple of years ago we
had a massive reorganization and our new
CEO Satya Nadella decides he's going to
reorganize the company to improve
performance right so you might think if
you would go and read the lid
our own organizational performance to
understand how he should do that well so
he he clearly didn't do that and and I
would say he probably shouldn't have
done that because he just would have
spent several years reading all of these
110 distinct theories and he would have
just gotten very confused by the end of
it but you would you would think naively
perhaps that the field of organization
science exists precisely to help people
like Satya Nadella
decide how to reorganize the company
that there should be at some level and
maybe that's not of course that's not
the only reason why we might have a
science but you think that there'd be
some objective in organization science
to to address questions that come from
practice and yet you know at least back
in the 1980s the authors that I was
reading concluded that there really
wasn't any such relationship and they
were really calling out for the field to
address this problem and so it's
particularly interesting that you know
24 years later there's another paper
also published in organization science
that says you know we have made any
progress on this right this is exactly
the same situation that were facing
today and there was a even more recent
article in in the in 2015 by Gerry Davis
saying you know more or less the same
thing so we have this sort of very kind
of persistent problem in this one field
where we just keep producing theories of
things and we sort of never get around
to figuring out how these theories fit
together and how collectively we can
take them and use them to inform
practical problems and I would say this
is probably true it's certainly true of
anything that I've spent any time trying
to learn about in social science there
may be areas of social science that I
don't know about where this has been
totally figured out and solved but it
hasn't been solved in anything that I
know anything about okay so if we think
about individual you know theories of
individual action or models of diffusion
or adoption or or collective action or
cooperation or anything to do with
systemic risk and find
antral systems certainly anything about
government or politics we have lots and
lots of theories that just kind of sit
around in parallel and you know
different people become engaged with
different theories but we don't ever
seem to take up the task of trying to
reconcile them and I remember noticing
this you know back in the late 1990s
when I was first sort of studying models
of adoption and I read this famous paper
by Mark Granovetter called threshold
models of collective action as published
in 1978 and it's beautiful paper very
elegant very persuasive and then I read
another paper by victim Donny Hirsch
lifer and Walters was published in 1992
which is also about contagion and and
and and and and social collective
behavior and a couple of things were
interesting about these two papers one
is that the introductory paragraphs
invoked exactly the same set of
motivating examples so they were all
they're both papers are concerned with
you know crowd behavior and riots and
and financial bubbles and and crises and
other kinds of interesting collective
social phenomenon that seem to sort of
come out of nowhere but the other thing
that was interesting to me is that the
models themselves were we're actually
incompatible with each other
like I could not it's impossible to
translate one model into the other right
that they have logically distinct
assumptions it's not possible for both
of these models to be right okay it's
possible that they're both wrong but
they can't both be right
it's possible that they could both be
right under different domains right but
they're actually talking about the same
domain so there's this sort of really
serious problem that we are we have
these theories that can't both be right
that claim to be talking about the same
thing and so I was surprised not just
that this was sort of still going on but
that apparently nobody else had even
noticed this problem right that you just
have people who follow a grin avetis
paper and you have people who followed
Victor and Danny at all and they just
talk past each other so why is this able
to persist so I'm going to talk a little
bit about that but I think you know why
is it matter well I think you know if we
think that doing social science is
motivated by the desire to inform social
practice make the world a better place
whatever you know all the reasons that
we got into doing social science in the
first place or at least that I got into
doing social science in the first place
we should be troubled by this
observation so you know one reason that
I bring this up is that there's been a
lot of excitement recently about
computational social science and how
we've been sort of struggling for a
hundred years now to get really good
data on individual individual behavior
and and interactions or think networks
at scale over time right so this is an
enormous kind of data collection problem
and social scientists have struggled
with this problem for many years and
then sort of almost all of a sudden it
seems we have all this data that is
delivering almost for free exactly or
approximately the type of data that
we've been that we've been asking for
and so and in addition to that we are
also able to do experiments in a in a
very different way than we've done in
the past and we're hearing some more
about that in the next couple of days
at the same time all of this digital
revolution is kind of in some ways
pushing traditional social science
questions sort of into people's faces
right it's making it's raising
interesting questions about how labor
markets are organized about you know
what kind of information should be
available about individual level
behavior about human productivity how we
solve problems how we interact
economically how we engage in commerce
so the
sort of an two things going on at the
same time one is that the world is
changing in ways that make traditional
social science questions kind of more
salient to a larger group of people and
also that we have new capabilities and
new tools that help us answer those
questions and so you might think that
this problem that I've been talking
about might get resolved if we that
maybe that maybe the problem is just
that we need better data we need better
tools and we need you no more computer
scientists helping out or more
physicists getting interested in social
science questions and indeed there has
been a tremendous amount of activity and
excitement over the last ten years you
know we have you know I mean only a few
years ago that people even cited using
the phrase computational social science
and now we have you know we have
meetings about it we have a big
conference in June in northwestern
International Conference for
computational social science and it's
you know only the second time to have
had this conference and it's amazing how
many people you know we have hundreds
and hundreds of submissions large
numbers of really top-notch invited
speakers some of them from from from
this room so there is really an
astounding amount of interest and
acceleration of interest in this in this
topic but when you sort of step back
from the papers and all the sort of you
know hundreds of analyses of things
happening on Twitter right and I've
contributed to this literature of things
happening on Twitter so I know about it
it's sort of you know we don't really
care about Twitter right I mean we study
Twitter because we have data about
things spreading on Twitter but you know
really we would like to understand how
behavior changes or how systemic risk
spreads through networks of financial
institutions or how epidemics emerge and
can be managed how organizations perform
so we study certain things because they
can be studied but we're not really
having an impact I would say on the
kinds of question
that again we originally cared about so
I think the problem is not just that we
lack data right that we I think we do
lack data and we have historically lack
data and so to some extent all of this
new data is indeed interesting and
exciting and valuable but I think that
even if we had ten or a hundred times as
much data as we have now we still
wouldn't have solved this bookshelf
problem that I'm talking about because
it's really a question of orientation
that if we want to solve social problems
than we have to actually think about
solving social problems and I would say
that social science is actually not
about that that in fact the way we are
trained in social science and the way we
are cultured in social science and in
fact in most Sciences I mean I'm not
saying social sciences is sort of
egregious in any sense the way things
are in general is that we are very
Theory driven that we start off in life
in grad school or even in undergrad and
you start off you know don't start off
as a social scientist you're trained as
an economist or a political scientist or
a sociologist or a psychologist and
you're taught about different theories
of the world and how they inform
different kinds of problems and so you
come out of that training and you have a
theoretical view of the world you have a
theoretical framework and very often you
have a methodological framework as well
that goes along with that and you take
that toolbox and you go and you apply it
to problem X problem Y problem Z
meanwhile your colleague over in a
different department has a different
theoretical framework in a different
toolbox and they are also addressing the
same problems XY and Z but the output
that you produce is very often
incompatible or very difficult to
compare and again if you go and read a
sociology paper about collective action
and you read an economics paper about
collective action
you know the titles look the same but
after that it's it's difficult to see
how these people are actually talking
about the same thing okay and it's
because they have these very different
theoretical frameworks that they bring
today
and you might think well that's fine you
know that's actually good to have a
diversity of approaches to these complex
problems and I would agree with that but
it really depends on how those
approaches are integrated with each
other and what kind whether or not they
have any kind of useful interaction with
each other and I would say that the way
we have organized ourselves is that they
do not that we publish in separate
journals and they just think these
things go out into the world and they
just sit there and they talk past each
other so how would we change this and
it's it's sort of the subtle seeming
change but I think it is fundamental
that if you start just with a problem we
just wake up one day and say I'm
interested in this problem I don't know
whether it's called sociology I don't
know whether it's called economics I
don't know whether its corporate I don't
know what it's called right I just know
that it's a problem in the world and
problems in the world don't particularly
respect disciplinary boundaries they
just are whatever they are and let me
bring all the tools that I know about to
bear on this problem and you know let's
see if computer scientists know
something and let's see if physicists
know something let's see if economists
knows something let's see if
psychologists know something and
everybody will know something and they
will all know different things and then
let's force these things to talk to each
other until we actually understand the
problem and this is really I think what
non social scientists want when they
come and talk to social scientists and I
remember reading a presidential address
to the American Sociological Association
back in the late 1940s and the the
president was was talking about this
problem he was saying you know people
come to sociologists and say you know I
want help with my problem and we tell
them that their problem is much more
complicated than they understood and
they are not grateful for this advice
they go away and they never come and
talk to us again right and you might
think well that's just because they're
there they're misinformed and they don't
understand what sociology is about and
and I think many sociologists feel that
way but you could also say
well maybe they maybe maybe we should
try right maybe we should try to help
them in the way that you know engineers
help people when they come and ask them
for problems and so I think this you
know again I've spent several years now
almost ten years now in in corporate
research labs at Microsoft and it Yahoo
and I've worked a lot with with
engineers computer scientists and and in
an environment where you know we're not
sort of we don't have product managers
coming to us and saying solve my problem
right we do basic science much like
everybody else but there is sort of a an
aura or a sort of surrounding mission
that is problem oriented that there are
that there's a sense that there are real
problems out there that need to be
addressed and what do you got that can
help with those problems and so so I
think this is you know something that
I've just been absorbing from hanging
around engineers for a lot but it is
definitely an approach that is very
familiar within the engineering
community and and and even and really
within the computer science community
and so you know this isn't just one of
many examples that you might think of
but when I when I'm trying to articulate
what I mean by a problem I think of
problems like this so you think about
you know driverless vehicles you know
one really knows how to build a
driverless vehicle and an ordinary
person doesn't think I can build a
driverless vehicle they think that
sounds like a really hard problem but I
know exactly what you mean right
I could I could tell you when your
vehicle is successfully driving without
a driver right so it's sort of a it's
conceptually a very easy problem to
understand it's very easy to verify
right and it's very hard to do so you
know this is sort of a and you might
think well why do we want driverless
vehicles like driving is a solved
problem right we have people who you
know people can drive cars why would we
divide a tremendous amount of effort to
doing something with a computer that we
already know how to do as humans and you
know one answer might be that well
even if you don't care about that it's
gonna generate a lot of interesting
science along the way that there is a
very clear objective in order to get to
that objective we have to solve a lot of
high technical problems in i-ight
and those solutions will be valuable for
lots of things that you might care about
it and finally it's just cool right it's
just there's something about there's
something kind of awesome about a
driverless vehicle right or robot baking
a cake right which is maybe the sort of
dumbest thing you could ask a robot to
do but the fact that you can get a robot
to bake a cake is just kind of cool
right
it makes people excited it attracts
funding and it generates other kinds of
consequences so it and it has some nice
features from from a research
perspective which is that when you when
you set your goal as solving a problem
and you say I don't care what you call
it I don't care what disciplines you
need I don't care where you publish your
pipe is right just solve the problem you
naturally integrate different fields you
naturally integrate different approaches
because you have to write because nobody
can do it on their own or effect well if
they can't do it on our own that's fine
great they can do it on their own
probably they cannot if you've chosen a
non-trivial problem in which case they
have to work together
it has a nice outcome metric right the
car either drives a software does not
drive itself right it's very sort of
straightforward to evaluate and along
the way you can build a lot of you know
even if you don't solve the original
problem you might still build something
useful so for example search engines
were originally supposed to organize the
world's knowledge right this was maybe
not a particularly well formed goal and
probably it hasn't been realized but I
think we will all agree that search
engines are useful right they maybe they
didn't solve the original problem but in
attempting to solve the original problem
they solve lots of really interesting
useful problems and we are glad that we
have search engines today so you might
also be thinking well that's fine you
know engineers can do this sort of thing
but this approach this doesn't make
sense in social science I think
that's a reasonable reaction you know I
mean growing up I would often hear
people sort of utter this phrase you
know if we can put a man on the moon why
can't we do X where X is some sort of
difficult intractable social problem
like ending poverty or or building World
Peace or whatever and it just sort of
seems like putting a man on the moon is
a really really difficult thing and you
know helping people out of poverty is
not nearly as difficult so why can we do
the first thing and we can't do the
second thing and I think we probably
know the answer to that that they're
just different sorts of problems that
these engineering problems have exactly
the properties that I mentioned on the
previous slide that they're very well
defined you know when you've you've
solved them and many problems in society
we can't even agree really on what the
problem is and as soon as we sort of get
into an argument about it it becomes
clear that everybody has all sorts of
different agendas and outcome metrics so
so that's certainly true and I think
that that kind of puts a lot of possible
problems off the table
right I think it's also true that that
there are instances where social
scientists have contributed very useful
valuable insights to to real problems
and a colleague of mine at NYU when I
was talking about this said well you
know what about the Earned Income Tax
Credit right this is something that
sociologists came up with and it has
demonstrably reduced poverty and I
thought wow I don't know is that a good
example it's kind of a good example it's
like a it's a really good thing but it's
not clear to me that the world would not
have figured out the Earned Income Tax
Credit without the help of sociologists
right and I think it's certainly not
clear - you know it's not clear in the
sense that you're not going to figure
out how to build the driverless car on
your own and you know this is possibly
an unfair comparison and I you know I
actually have spent a lot of time
writing and thinking about how unfair it
is that people think everything in
social science is obvious even when it's
not but
it would be nice if we could find
something that was clearly not obvious
right that we could say this is a
problem you agree it's a problem you
agree that you don't know how to solve
it we solved it okay and here's the
here's the demonstration you might also
say well this is really just missing the
point right that you know sociology and
actually I think many sociologists would
say this is missing the point right that
sociology is not actually ever intended
to solve problems what sociology does is
provide theoretical frameworks it
provides people ways of thinking about
the world that they didn't have before
and you know possibly even a critical
way of thinking about the world that
they didn't have before
and once they have that way of thinking
they then go out and they solve the
problems that they had to solve in a
different way and that's useful right
it's like a different kind of way of
helping people and I think that's
actually perfectly legitimate and I'm
certainly not saying that all of social
science or even most of social science
should drop what it's doing and start
trying to think like engineers but it
might be the case that some part of
social science could try this and what
would it mean to take this seriously
what would we have to do and so this is
this is basically what we've been
arguing about in this these meetings
that we've been having over the last
couple of years we can all think of
problems like you know stopping climate
change or you know ending poverty that
we would love to be able to solve but
they just seem wildly intractable and
then you know there are lots of things
that we can think of which are just sort
of like of the flavor of my next
research paper right that we know we
could do but somehow seem not ambitious
enough so can we find problems that are
in this Goldilocks zone of you know big
ambitious problems that we can set
ourselves but where we hope that we can
make some progress and ideally we can
make some sort of progressive progress
where there's you know more and less
difficult versions of the problems such
that the easiest version is something we
feel you know we can we can we can
probably do that in the next you know if
we brought together the right group of
people and the right resources we could
probably
make some really serious progress on
that problem in the next five years or
ten years and then there's sort of a
much harder more open version of that
that that we can that we can work on
over a longer timeframe the next
criteria is that it's it's still doing
science right I mean there's obviously
lots and lots of entities out there in
the world outside of academia that
really that try to solve real problems
and that often take insights from social
science so we have you know lots of
consulting companies and NGOs and agent
government agencies that are really
focused on real problems and sometimes
they are you know they have people with
a lot of academic training and this is
not that right this is not just here's
what I know here's my opinion right this
is this is actually trying to do science
and finally it has to be not creepy okay
and I think that if you again like if
social science were to do too good a job
of solving problems then it might it
might start to seem like social
engineering and that's something that we
wouldn't want to do so so then I think
really this just sort of sets up the the
rest of today and tomorrow
where well I said hope this sets up I
haven't really sort of coordinated too
carefully with my speakers so maybe
they'll they'll come up and talk about
something else entirely but I hope what
they're going to talk about is is to try
to sort of flesh out this this or trying
to address this challenge of like what
is you know what are some examples of
problems that might satisfy these
criteria where they're clearly important
they're clearly science problems and
they're not getting solved on their own
right that we that we're not just going
to you know if they're just going to get
figured out through the the the existing
process of social science then it's fine
we don't have to worry about it but
they're not so sprawling and complicated
that we can't imagine that with a single
group of people
the right people in a single place
possibly you know a place like this
place for example which I was just
reading about was a you know founder
there's an interdisciplinary research
institute in chemistry so you can
imagine within a single building they
made a lot of progress on some really
concrete problems is that something that
we could imagine doing in the social
sciences and along the way we'll have to
talk about other kinds of related issues
like what would we have to do about the
data that is available other what
problems do we need to address in terms
of found data versus design data what
kind of platforms would we have to build
what kind of organization would be
required to to do problem oriented
social science and I think I'm out of
time so I will I had some more thoughts
but I will I think this is a good place
as any to stop and I'll hand over to
soon oh thank you